there's an actual equation for women's
hormones versus men's hormones is that
correct yes I brought them yes I'd like
to see that let's talk about this okay
so women have the same hormones as men
they just all oscillating in different
ways right and this is just science
this isn't yes this is true so I never
make anything up these are real
equations look at that what's hold it
still so that we can get a good shot of
it this is women's hormone equation this
is real yeah this is a bit of calculus
for you hey economy rate of change yes
so women are interesting they get that
period once a month 28 days not the moon
chimpanzees every 35 days anyway I need
to do a bit more of this no no no no no
III love equations and graphs do you
mind me using this yes I've always never
I've had a talk show for 22 years and
I've never had gotten once to use one of
these and go let's proceed women's
hormone equations correct your hair is
very pretty I feel like I should show
you the men's one yeah okay so this is a
woman's hormone equation explain how
they're hormones how does the 28-day
cycle get set up he's very interesting
because women are born with all their
eggs which is interesting evolutionary
speaking because you put all this energy
you know men they just create you know a
couple of million when they want to they
just go men go what just go hey hey yeah
I'm in the mood
[Applause]
okay let's show this the actual men's
equation because I thought it was
important yes to compare the two and for
you to see so here the men's equations
oh my these are all real this explains
so much oh well guess what I have
another one look at this this yes yes I
see what you're doing here so this is
everything that goes into a man you know
No well well yes so men are interesting
because they have the same hormones as
women they have a huge peak in the
morning and a huge slump in the evening
and it's not just some gradual decline
it's up and down so the men so men have
a they they are up in the morning up in
the morning and then there's such quick
drop-off no it drops all as the day goes
the day goes by and then over here it's
I just want to watch SportsCenter and
shoot and shoot Cheez Whiz into my mouth
that's what this is right there anyway
so men's hormones actually so every two
to two and a half hours it oscillates so
I always tell my girlfriends I might as
well tell you as well that if you ask a
guy a favor and he doesn't respond just
wait half an hour and ask again
interesting just keep trying to get him
on that [ __ ] little slope during the day
do you when you're on a date do you
bring this stuff out
all right I have to ask you one last
question you're writing another book
what's it about I tell you the working
title can't decide okay well what's it
going to be but yeah what's the working
title clitoris calculus do you think
it's true outrageous no I think it'd be
coming back very soon you're talking us
together about clitoris calculus I'm
just trying to get people turned on to
math really yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
mathematics things sex is available now
would you come back because it's really
fun talking to you can I talk to you
about clitoris calculus yes